bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission pays
a enregistré sa neuvième victoire de la
saison en fédérale 3 les plaisirs oies
se sont largement imposés à domicile
contre dunkerque sur le score de 41 5
les détaillants son magazine course à
pied la 8e édition du bike and run du
roi était organisé ce week-end à
versailles autour de la pièce d'eau des
suisses
plus de mille personnes ont fait le
déplacement pour participer à la
compétition reportage à suivre
football l'équipe senior masculine
d'elancourt cointre actuellement la
cinquième place du classement de 2e
division de district à trois points du
leader à monter donc envisageable nous
recevrons les qui dans quelques instants
sur ce plateau
et puis l'essentiel de l'actualité
sportive du week-end dans le département
nous parlons notamment du tournoi de
boxe éducative qui s'est déroulée ce
week-end à la verrière les semaines se
suivent et se ressemblent pour le
plaisir rugby-club les yvelinois ont
enregistré leur neuvième victoire de la
saison en fédérale 3 les pays roi se
sont imposés largement imposé à domicile
contre dunkerque sur le score de 41 5
les images sont saignés à florennes
parfait on ne les arrête plus plaisir
leader de la poule 1 de fédérale 3 avant
les fêtes a conservé son trône
les yvelinois se sont largement imposés
contre dunkerque sur le score de 41 5
une démonstration collective on a eu des
séquences de jeu qui était vraiment
magnifique collectivement et avec des
escales au bout en plus donc ce qui a
fonctionné ce qui commence à bien
fonctionner c'est çà et là on l'année un
petit peu satisfait parce que on
travaille pour ça quoi
les + 0 1 pourtant batailler en première
période le score n'était que de 14 à 5 à
la pause à la mi-temps on sait on s'est
mis un petit coup de boost on s'est dit
que c'était important de montrer autre
chose montre un autre visage sur la
deuxième mi temps et du coup bas chose
qu'on a fait quand on a resserré un
petit peu tout ça sur la deuxième et ça
fait la différence sur le match france
avec cette performance plaisir affiche
désormais un bilan de neuf victoires en
dix matches disputés cette saison
fédérale 3 un parcours qui devrait les
propulser en fédérale 2 l'année
prochaine
tous les dimanches on a à coeur de
prouver que bon bah on n'était pas en
fédérale 2 en arrière pour rien et et on
l'a dit notre objectif est de remonter
donc voilà il faut le prouver tous les
week-ends on reste très noble match de
rugby c'est un match de rugby
anouk incarnant la grosse tête plaisir
se déplacera sur le terrain d'evreux
pour le compte de la 11e journée du
championnat l'équipe que les yvelinois
avait dominé 17 à 6 lors des phases
aller si tout sourit à plaisir rien ne
va plus pour versailles les joueurs de
la cité royale se sont lourdement
inclinés ce week-end contre epernay
score final 33 13 conséquence versailles
est bon dernier de fédérale 3 et la
descente semble se dessiner
le montage est signée romain respini le
rugby-club de verseilles s'enfonce dans
la crise après dix journées les joueurs
de la cité royale pointe à la dernière
place après la claque reçue ce le
dimanche 17 janvier contre epernay le
score 33 10 le club temps de trouver des
explications
on a eu beaucoup de choses à la fois on
a eu un entraîneur qui ont changé pour
la troisième année consécutive on a eu
aussi cinq de départ pas lié à des
crises de entre les joueurs mais tu es
fan cycle des groupes qui commence à
changer l'échangé de deux pointes de
kimberley jouer ailleurs et en fait on a
perdu beaucoup d'abord rien n'assure
tout autre recruter des trois-quarts
donc il nous manque des avants et c'est
compliqué
malgré un bilan de huit défaites en dix
matches 275 points encaissés six points
de retard sur l'avant-dernier et verse
ayant toujours une infime chance
d'accrocher le maintien on n'a pas le
choix de façon il faut qu'on
faut pas qu'on reste à la dernière place
qu'on doit on doit sauver le club et
voilà on a on a tous les matches retour
pour pouvoir faire pour pouvoir faire
parce qu'il faut pour pouvoir au moins
sortir que ces deux places je pense que
c'est jouable
honnêtement oui c'est jouable mais on y
reste tous les matchs retour a trait à
faire il n'y a pas de raison quand on
n'est pas encore mort prochain match
pour versailles le dimanche 24 janvier à
15 heures à domicile contre boulogne
billancourt sans doute la dernière
cartouche dé versailles et pour éviter
une descente après neuf saisons passées
en fédérale 3 après une large page rugby
on passe au cyclisme sur piste
la troisième étape de la coupe du monde
aussi de cyclisme sur piste était
programmée à ce week-end à hong kong le
trappistes benjamin thomas brillé en
remportant le scratch et la course aux
points
ils montrent un françois pervis a lui
réussi son pari en s'inclinant en
demi-finale de vitesse individuelle
chez les filles la plaisir oise 210
claire a terminé à la sixième place de
la vitesse par équipes avec sa
coéquipière olivia montauban nous avions
justement rencontré la pistarde de
l'équipe de france juste avant l'épreuve
nous sommes avec la plaisir oise 110
claire championne d'europe de vitesse en
2010 multiple championne de france là
nous sommes à quelques semaines des
championnats du monde qui se dérouleront
à londres du 2 au 6 mars
est ce que vous êtes prête tout
simplement 110 prête c'est un grand mot
générique pour l'instant il ya d'abord
une première étape
une dernière étape plus tôt avant le les
mondiaux c'est la coupe du monde la
semaine prochaine donc on va d'abord
faire cette étape et puis après on
finalisera la préparation après la coupe
du monde donc je serai prête pour les
championnats du monde mais pour
l'instant on peut pas dire que je suis
prête et qu'elles seront du coup les
prochaines étapes jusqu'au jusqu'au
championnat du monde vous allez vous
préparer peut être physiquement encore
plus pour être le plus performant
possible
oui mais en fait ce tout au long de la
saison donc la forme arrive crescendo
parce que bon on peut pas être en forme
tout au long de la saison et j'avais dit
on va être en forme olympique tout le
temps
mais donc voilà c'est vraiment crescendo
après il ya des étapes comme les plus du
monde où il faut être quand même un
minimum en forme parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de concurrence donc c'est important
d'être un minimum compétitrices sur sur
ses échéances
il ya une grosse passe de
musculation peut-être de travail
physique là ces dernières semaines c'est
comme comme toute la saison qu'on a pu
faire
oui la musculation on va un peu
l'atténuer en arrivant sur les sur les
mondiaux mais pour l'instant voilà on
est encore dans une phase de travail
les coupes du monde c'est vraiment des
étapes c'est important de ne pas les
rater
mais il faut pas oublier que l'objectif
principal reste les mondiaux et cette
année les jeux aussi derrière les
dernières étapes de coupe du monde se
sont pas très bien passées par exemple
en nouvelle zélande s'est pas très bien
passé pour vous non c'était un peu
difficile voilà un peu compliqué j'ai eu
une grosse période de fatigue avant donc
voilà il faut le temps de se remettre de
tout ça c'est c'est pas facile ça
revient pas en un claquement de doigts
et on ça revient pas non plus en deux
entraînements donc voilà je recommence à
faire quelques chronos et pas encore mes
meilleurs chronos mais ça remonte donc
c'est de bonne augure pour la suite et
finalement dans une année olympique
comment comment on l'a préparé ce qu'on
vise absolument les jeux olympiques ou
est ce qu'on vise les championnats du
monde d'autres étapes tout au long de la
saison
ou est-ce que voilà on se focalise que
sur les jeux olympiques
ben en fait pour aller aux jeux
olympiques il faut passer par des
épreuves de sélection que c'est les
coupes du monde les chemins du monde et
les europe donc il faut pas les oublier
parce que si on les fait pas on marque
pas de points donc on ne part pas au jeu
donc voilà c'est un peu particulier
cette saison parce que voilà il faut
avoir évidemment l'objectif des jeux en
tête ça doit être le plus gros mais à
côté de ça il faut pas oublier les
étapes qui peut y avoir avant et dans ce
groupe france chez les filles ça se
passe comment là en ce moment le
l'ambiance est au beau fixe
ah oui non il ya un seuil à un seul
objectif c'est les jeux un oui voilà nos
échéances oui en fait on
on est toutes ensemble parce que la
vitesse par équipes va qualifier donc la
vitesse pratiquée plus des individuels
en vitesse et en keirin
on peut également y aller en individuel
mais en tout cas pour ma part je suis
trop loin dans les classements donc moi
voilà je vise la vitesse par équipes
avec mes coéquipières et on a tout
intérêt à être main dans la main parce
que il faut on se serre l'une de l'autre
pour nous qualifier en fait donc c'est
important que l'on s'entende bien et
qu'on aille tous dans le même sens on
parle beaucoup en sont des garçons de
françois pervis de grégory baugé fin de
toute l'équipe de france masculine mais
l'équipe de france féminine peut ramener
aussi une médaille aux jeux olympiques
à l'heure actuelle il faut être honnête
c'est compliqué là par rapport aux
sélections il faut rentrer dans les cinq
meilleures européennes par équipes on
est cinquième donc rien n'est joué rien
n'est gagné rien n'est perdu mais voilà
pour l'instant c'est vrai que
il faut être honnête une médaille ce
serait un peut viser haut mais voilà on
a d'abord comme objectif par don de se
qualifier pour les jeux et puis une fois
qu'on sera qualifié ce sera une autre
un autre objectif donc là peut-être
ramener une médaille bon après on n'y va
jamais pour pour perdre mais mais voilà
il faut être
il faut être honnête est conscient de ce
qu'on peut faire ou pas et comment
expliquez vous justement cette
différence entre les garçons et les
filles est ce que je sais pas il ya des
petits détails qui font la différence
chez les garçons peut être que vous
n'avez pas chez les filles où c'est tout
simplement
voilà les groupes qui ne sont pas du
même niveau tout simplement eux
ouais non jeu il n'y a pas d'explication
c'est on donne tout et tous le meilleur
de nous-mêmes après les garçons c'est
vrai que ils sont au niveau
international ils sont
mieux classé que nous les filles ils
sont plus forts certainement que nous
enfin je parle dans le ranking
évidemment ce que physiquement forcément
ils sont plus forts mais voilà n'ont pas
forcément d'explication en a le même
entraîneur donc j'ai bien on s'entraîne
comme eux donc
voilà c'est juste un manque de chance
aussi sur certains ne met pas trop de
chance c'est pas forcément de la chance
mais après moi j'ai une grosse période
de fatigue donc ça n'a pas aidé l'équipe
à rester bien placé dans le classement
donc voila mais bon c'est comme ça on
est toujours en course pour pour cette
qualification et on va rien lâcher parce
que c'est pas le moment de lâcher si
près du but
et pour vous quel serait l'année idéale
mais en 2016 du coup quelle serait la
plus grande en 2016 moi ce serait déjà
vraiment de retrouver mon niveau si je
reste
honnête avec moi même ce serait de
retrouver mon niveau et puis de partir
au jeu et faire une perf au jeu du
beurre c'est à dire c'est à dire battre
mon record
enfin et dirait mon record sur le tour
personnellement et puis après le record
de l'équipe parce que voilà pour moi
c'est la vitesse par équipes et si je
bats mon record sur le premier tour se
dire que derrière je la lance beaucoup
plus vite donc elle peut venir beaucoup
plus vite donc on peut faire un chrono
que l'équipe de france n'a jamais fait
en tout cas on vous le souhaite
merci beaucoup c'est un hitler mais
avant de parler football avec nos
invités du jour on parle running la 8e
édition du bike and run du roi était
organisé ce week-end à versailles autour
de la pièce d'eau des suisses
plus de mille personnes ont fait le
déplacement pour participer à la
compétition
une épreuve qui s'est déroulée sous la
neige les images sont signés à florennes
parfait
c'est désormais une tradition à
versailles la 8e édition du bike and run
du roi s'est déroulée ce dimanche 17
janvier autour de la pièce d'eau des
suisses
au programme un parcours de 12 8 km qui
allie à la fois des zones techniques et
des zones un peu pointu
remuez 30 connais pratiquement 13
kilomètres à faire ce qui peut paraître
peu mais qui lorsqu'on a fait
c'est bon
des zones techniques avec des singles
dans les bois il manque effectivement de
la technicité a pas en vélo et course à
pied
et puis les parties très très aimante
qui permet de se regrouper de récupérer
cette année la neige s'est invitée
pendant le rendez vous sportif rendant
les conditions de course plus extrêmes
un peu de repos 3
connaissant très très facile mais en
croatie ont des positions qui seront
recherchés par les concurrents ça permet
de s'amuser ranimer savary et vendre
inerte
on s'en souviendra dans l'épreuve
masculine fabien combaluzier a remporté
pour la cinquième fois en six ans la
course du roi sportifs licenciés à
versailles est monté sur la plus haute
marche du podium avec son coéquipier
cris lane le bihan avec un temps de 43
minutes et 24 secondes
j'avais surtout aujourd'hui un équipier
au top de sa forme qu'a fait la
différence
je lui avais demandé avant l'épreuve de
courir deux fois plus que moi et
franchement je crois qu'il l'a fait donc
on s'est lancé le défi on a haussé à
peut pas préparer et puis on est allé on
savait pas trop on espérait jouer
pouvoir jouer devant mais on ne
penserait pas trop les places meiway
l'atc super super pour ça au total la
compétition réunit plus de 1000 coureurs
au regard du succès rencontré une
neuvième édition devrait être programmée
en 2017
on continue donc ce magazine par du
football l'équipe senior masculine
d'elancourt pointe actuellement la
cinquième place du classement à trois
points de la première place pour nous
parler de la situation du club nous
recevons sur ce plateau le président
philippe libotte l'éducateur de l'équipe
senior daniel des oliveira salim icade
line est le capitaine
hamadi diouf bonsoir à tous les quatre
bonsoir merci de passer sur ce plateau
alors tout d'abord nous avons parlé de
ce match de ce week-end contre magny les
hameaux
un match que vous avez perdu 1-0 à match
que vous avez dominé et que vous n'avez
pas gagné exactes sont tombés sur une
belle équipe de magny les hameaux avec
un super gardien et je tenais à lui
rendre hommage et on n'a pas su marquer
les buts et au final on s'est pris un
but
on va dire d'une attention et on finit
par perdre 1 0 et c'est vraiment une
contre performance vraiment cette
défaite ça coup d'arrêt non c'est pas un
coup d'arrêt voilà c'est quelque chose
qui arrive hein c'est comme ça on a peur
on n'a pas su tuer le match comme on dit
donc quoi ça arrive ça fait partie du
football c'est des points qui sont
importants pour la suite peut-être du
championnat physique
oui c'est des points qui sont qui sont
importants mais voilà le principal c'est
surtout de gagner à la maison
après il peut y avoir des accidents
l'extérieur c'est engranger le maximum
de points quand on est à la maison et
puis voilà des accidents ça arrive et
puis c'est pas de problème quoi c est ca
feriez et c'est plus un accident où
c'est peut-être un manque de préparation
par rapport au match je sais pas par
rapport par rapport aux faits depuis la
trêve et pendant pendant plusieurs
semaines je dirais pas que c'est un
accident ni un manque de préparation
c'est c'est nous c'est un manque de
lucidité c'est un manque de réalisme
dans ce match est il des fêtes comme ça
d'entrée de jeu après la trêve ça peut
casser la dynamique d'un groupe qui
était quand même plutôt bien parti en
championnat
non je pense pas je pense pas l'europe a
l'air a l'air d'être bien bien ensemble
je vois des garçons qui viennent à
l'entraînement ils sont ils sont
contents d'être là on a on a changé le
coach et ça marche plutôt bien il ya une
bonne une bonne ambiance je trouve donc
non la dynamique elle va revenir et puis
voilà quelques matchs et des bons
entraînements puis c'est reparti vous
confirmez
tout à fait ce qui dit le président
c'est l'objectif du club on veut monter
cette année vous allez monter de plus
cette année
du coup alors laissé c'est l'objectif
fixé d'objectif on veut monter cette
année on va faire tout notre possible
pour monter cette année mais c'est pas
gagné d avance faut travailler pour ça
un autre mot donc sur le plan du jeu
vous avez marqué 20 buts depuis le début
du championnat en avait encaissé 19
par contre vous êtes une équipe du coup
plutôt équilibré peut-être c'est ça
l'objectif votre plan de jeu en tout cas
de sur l'équipe non du tout notre plan
de jeu en fait c'est de marquer des buts
est pas en prendre
sauf qu'à chaque fois on réussit à
prendre des buts sur des fautes
d'inattention et
on peut s'en vouloir qu'à soi-même en
fait et donc c'est pas un jeu plutôt
portée vers la défense peut-être du tout
non on essaye d'aller vers l'avant tout
en en faisant du jeu parce que j'ai de
la chance d'avoir des joueurs techniques
dans mon équipe donc en profiter et
faire du jeu et faire du jeu vers
l'avant
donc vous avez conservant le bol donc
vous avez marqué 20 buts 17 qui ont été
marqués du coup par notre invité qui est
présente en ce moment 17 buts vous avez
marqué vous êtes en pleine réussite
cette saison
oui c'est grâce à mes coéquipiers qui
nous font briller ils vous font la passe
au bon moment et moi je me pose pas de
questions devant le coude but je dirais
ça fait ça fait but pour nuit je me
prends pas la tête
philippe ibos un petit peu votre matane
c'est ça oui en quelque sorte c'est bien
non mais un attaquant qu'il faut baffo
qui marque des buts donc c'est non c'est
très bien et puis c'est très bien ça
fait de la confiance et puis c'est une
très très bonne chose pour l'équipe
bon c'est vrai qu il est là donc c'est
très bien c'est très bien et puis il ya
les équipiers qui lui donne des ballons
qu'il faut donc c'est très bien
voulais rajouter les choses j'aimerais
ajouter quelque chose c'est que il
marque des buts parce qu'il fait preuve
de sérieux à l'entraînement et il est un
total de 100 % de de présence à
l'entraînement il ya également salim
aussi qui a qui a marqué quelques buts
cette saison 7 buts je crois c'est ici
que sont bâle toute compétition avec les
matches de coupe jean mais deux en
championnat
je suis à sept passes décisives 7 passes
décisives que je mets mon attaque en
quoi un maudit et donc ça fait plaisir
qu'on met une passe décisif et que
l'attaquant imart est là quand je vois
il a 17 buts ça fait plaisir parce qu'il
soulage toute l'équipe comme on en parle
et voilà on a on a un groupe et on fait
ce qu'on veut c'est former un groupe
c'était l'objectif du président et du
coach est vraiment c'est d'avoir un
groupe soudé voilà on a un groupe jeune
et c'est vraiment c'est le principal
c'est le budget principal c'est de soude
un groupe et dames
image du club du coup l'équipe n'est pas
trop tourner peut-être vers ahmadi
peut-être vu que c'est votre
avant-centre parce que l'équipe ne joue
pas trop pour lui non c'est une équipe
qui joue qui a un bon collectif et
apprendre à la chance d'avoir un
finisseur comme un 10 qui marque des
buts et qui nous sauve qui nous a sauvé
plusieurs fois à plusieurs matchs voilà
mais c'est sinon l'équipe en elle-même
tout le monde et est concerné les c'est
ce qui fait la force et du coup le
groupe vit bien vous vous disiez tout à
l'heure salim le groupe vis à vis bien
le groupe vit bien
donc voilà c'est fait la force du coup
de c'est ce qui fait la force de cette
équipe c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on
travaille aussi à l'entraînement c'est
ce que le note coach m'ait fait en sorte
de mettre en place le président aussi
qui nous soutient qui est toujours là
qu'est la présence d'entraînement aussi
donc c'est vraiment c'est ce qu'on
travaille donc comme on voit là il ya le
championnat à côté et il ya les
entraînements de l'autre c'est vraiment
c'est le groupe sait ce qu'on veut c'est
ce qu'est ce qui fait la force d'une
équipe qu'on me le coach il dit et ce
groupe il doit progresser encore sur os
dans quels domaines c'est un groupe
assez jeune je crois que salim est le
plus âgé d'ailleurs du groupe le croit
que les 26 ans et sarlat j'ai 26 ans et
vous êtes le doyen de l'équipe pas le
doyen voilà je suis on va dire je suis
le capitaine
donc je suis le plus âgé j'ai 26 ans
donc je suis là j'essaie de parler avec
aussi avec les jeunes qui montent de u19
et donc voilà après ça fait toujours du
bien d'apporter notre la petite touche
d'expérience que j'ai pu avoir avec
d'autres clubs avec donc voilà et est-ce
que c'est peut-être un petit à petit
défaut quand même ce
ce manque d'expérience au final salim à
26 ans le reste du groupe a forcément
moins par exemple vous avez 22 ans à
6,24 à 24 ans 6 au 24 ans est ce que
justement ce manque d'expérience ne va
pas pêcher peut-être en fin de saison
quand il faudra engranger les points
importants à ce manque d'expérience on
le voit déjà au jour d'aujourd'hui on
aurait pu - ou être premier
déjà depuis longtemps on a trop péché
justement sur ce sur son manque
d'expérience a et ce qui nous a fait
perdre beaucoup beaucoup de points et
vous croyez encore à la montée
on y croit encore les premiers c'est ça
pendant sénat était en fait déjà la
journée tout à fait et vous avez chuté
petit à petit on a chuté et l'a3 pas
tout à fait donc tout est encore
possible
maintenant c'est c'est aux joueurs de se
prendre en main c'est à dire dans leur
mentalité grandir dessus et je pense que
si on y arrive si on arrive à 6 on
arrive justement à récupérer tous ses
défauts eh bien on pourra aller très
loin
vous y croyez vous les joueurs salim
vous y croyez pas vous y allez pour
cette année à la montée oui elle est
pour cette année donc voilà maintenant
on va jouer tous les matches à fond
quand on sait qu'il faut tout jouer à
fond le championnat comme l'avait bull
il est serré donc c'est on peut tous
faire une erreur si nous on a bien fait
ce week end les autres équipes peuvent
le faire aussi
ahmadi quelles seront les équipes
concurrentes pour cette montée cette
course à la montée il aura le premier
qui est rambouillet j'irai voisins aussi
comme on a perdu contre eux et
en dernier je redoute un petit peu
guyancourt parce qu'ils ont des bons
joueurs et voilà c'est tout après il ya
nous saluons la moins chère que dans la
danse et toutes les équipes parce qu on
s'est toutes les équipes toutes les
équipes veulent nous battre
sachant qu'au match aller on a battu
tout le monde donc toutes les équipes à
nous attendu et attendu au tournant
attendu au tournant et le coude c'est la
première chose qui nous a dit et c'est
la première chose qui nous a dit
dimanche déjà qu'est une équipe à qui
voilà on a gagné 3-0 au match aller au
match retour on savait que ça n'allait
pas être facile et donc malgré qu'on on
méritait peut-être la victoire on n'a
pas obtenu
donc ça peut ça peut être comme ça même
le dimanche d'après c'est un ou deux
dernières questions pour vous philippe
botte est ce que la montée serait un
bonus ou c'est une priorité
non c'est un bonus mais si les joueurs
sont en mesure d'aller la chercher il ya
aucun problème
c'est bien au contraire justement mais
ce n'est pas l'objectif l'objectif c'est
d'avoir un groupe avec une bonne
mentalité un bon comportement un groupe
solidaire avant intégrant les jeunes les
u19
si au bout il ya une montée ce sera avec
plaisir et
je pense que le club en deuxième
division enfin l'équipe senior n'est pas
sa place en deuxième division
donc oui je moi je leur souhaite de
monter s'ils peuvent le faire donc du
bonus s'ils brillent vote
merci à tous les cas d'être passé sur ce
plateau c'était un plaisir vous recevoir
pour cette émission bon courage pour la
suite de la saison
on passe maintenant aux autres résultats
du week-end on commence cette rubrique
résultats par du basket trappe n'en
finit plus de gagner en nationale 3
masculine
les hommes de mustapha el hafidi se sont
imposés sur leur parquet dans le derby
contre marly le roi le score est sans
appel 78 à 67
au classement les trappistes emmené par
le pivot jo et cassis et le meneur abgué
barakaou remonte doucement et saint
quentinois sont désormais à la 6e place
avec un bilan de 6 victoires et 6
défaites depuis le début de la saison
prochain match pour trappe samedi
prochain sur le terrain de viry
châtillon
on continue à part de la boxe le boxing
club de la verrière a organisé ce
week-end les championnats départemental
de boxe éducative assaut le club a
totalisé à cette occasion 13 champions
départementaux sur les 15 engagés saby
duick a remporté son combat en moins de
51 kg chez les garçons son frère jordan
a remporté la victoire en s'imposant
dans la catégorie des moins de 90 kg la
verrière organisera les championnats
d'île de france cadets dans trois
semaines on passe au handball a rien ne
va plus pour les féminines de
montigny-le-bretonneux les filles
coachées par philippe l'étrange se sont
inclinés à l'extérieur sur le terrain de
landi lampaul
le score est très sévère pour les
yvelinoises 27 à 17 au classement
montigny sombre et s'éloigne un peu plus
du maintien en nationale une résine
monteyne son dernière du championnat
avec seulement deux matches gagnés en 12
journées
le prochain match contre nantes à
domicile une rencontre programmée hier
programmée le 6 février s'annonce
capital enfin on termine ce magazine à
part du rugby le sky affiche toujours
100% de victoires en promotion d'honneur
les saint quentinois se sont imposés sur
leur terrain 7 à 3 dans le derby vinoy
contre l'entente le ch est née de la
celle saint cloud une victoire au
forceps qui fait le bonheur du sky au
classement les hommes coachés par thomas
payan sont toujours premier avec 5
points d'avancé sur le 2e clairement
c'est la fin de 7,8 sport merci d'avoir
suivi on se retrouve lundi prochain pour
un nouveau magazine à 10 il a passé une
excellente semaine sportive très belle
soirée sur tv fil 78